le 30 août dernier sami damerdji maire
de mantes la ville est menacée de mort
par un tag devant son hôtel de ville
début juillet son confrère de mantes la
jolie raphaël cogny faisait face à la
même situation créant un sentiment
d'insécurité grandissant chez les élus
yvelinois élu maire de plaisir depuis
joséphine coleman ce berger ressent
cette augmentation de la violence
je compatis auprès de mes collègues par
rapport à tout ce qu'ils ont pu subir
moi même j'ai eu il ya quelques temps
aussi des agressions et aussi j'ai reçu
des menaces par écrit j'ai reçu un
caillou sur sur une jambe alors sa
paille qui gravissime et le geste en soi
n'est pas acceptable
il n'y a pas eu vraiment de poursuites
par rapport à ça il va falloir aussi que
la population comprenne que nous ne
devons pas être des punching-balls on
doit pas être là des boucs émissaires de
tous et de tout ce stress bien sûr qui
est dans la société on est là au
contraire pour les accompagner
du côté de lévis saint nom la première
édile and green on le reconnaît elle n'a
jamais eu à subir cette violence mais
souhaitent tout de même plus de
sanctions toute mesure qui permettra de
combattre ce sentiment d'impunité et de
rétablir l'autorité du maire sera
évidemment la bienvenue à la violence
envers les élus est un sujet évidemment
extrêmement grave et qu'il faut
combattre
on a eu quelques quelques exemples cet
été un de mer qui avait été frappée et
insultée serra et pour lesquels il n'y a
eu que des 2 simple rappel à la loi donc
c'est évidemment absolument inacceptable
un souhait entendu par le ministre de la
justice eric dupond moretti
depuis le 7 septembre les insultes
envers les mères sont désormais
qualifiées d' outrage impliquant la mise
en oeuvre de travaux d'intérêt général